这个问题问得特别有意思，因为长久以来你一直在讲怎么精雕细琢写出漂亮的 Rails 和 Ruby 代码，而现在你却在几个月内彻底转变了做法。那么，你现在的
工作方式是什么样的？因为我猜你依然追求那种美感、那种精雕细琢、那种匠心，只不过是在不同的媒介、不同的抽象层面上施展。当我在写 Ruby
代码的时候，而且我们有大量的 Ruby 代码，因为整个业务都建立在它之上，我让智能体去改动这些代码时，我依然会抠细节。
嗯。但我逐渐意识到，这种抠细节带来的经济回报正在迅速递减。我之所以 25 年来对每一行代码都如此审慎地较真，是因为我知道，保持架构
连贯、可塑，换来的是一款能快速迭代演进、小团队就能搞定、成本可控、改动一处不会引发一堆 bug 的软件。这才是背后的核心经济逻辑——
为什么要写漂亮的代码，因为漂亮的代码更好理解、更简单、更可塑。但这一切的前提是人来做修改。现在这个前提在多大程度上还成立，我觉得是个开放问题。当然
它现在仍然重要，我之所以这么说，至少目前是这样，是因为此时此刻 token 仍然是稀缺资源。我们都受 token 的限制。嗯，不是所有人，但只要预算不是无限的，就都受限。所以，
写那种让智能体更容易处理、更容易演进的系统，回报是巨大的，它们不用重新学习整个上下文。就跟人一样，如果能对代码库做迭代和修改而不破坏
整体架构，那下一次改动就能和上一次一样便宜。而这正是经典的“泥球”——你最终得到一个变成泥球的系统，因为它拼接的方式让各个部分互不相连，就是一团乱麻。
对吧？我在智能体身上见过这种情况，也在我们自己的代码库里见过——第一个 PR 质量就平平，然后上面再叠一个 PR，再往后迭五个，
就不行了。所以抠细节仍然有回报，但这个回报是建立在我们当下这个时刻之上的。顺便说一句，这就是 AI 狂热真正上头的地方——当你试图去外推 9
个月后、两年后会是什么样的时候。但作为一个思想实验，我用的第一台电脑是 Commodore 64。
我也是。太酷了。
它有一颗 1 MHz 的 CPU 和 64K 内存。
嗯。
为那台机器写软件的每个人都把某些约束内化进了骨子里。当然，那台机器本身就是约束的集合。如果你把那个程序员放进时光机，传送到 2026 年，给他一台现代
电脑，说：“现在给我写个软件。”他们一开始会不知所措，因为他们所有的技巧、所有的直觉都会变得不适用——也不能说完全不适用，因为高效的软件依然是美的。他们
会跟不上自己能创造的价值。为了让 1 MHz 的电脑跑出电子游戏，你得做的优化量，跟今天要做的是完全两码事。
想象一下当年那个在 Commodore 上编程的人。回想一下那时候编程是什么感觉、意味着什么。资源极度受限，一切都那么慢。
从很多方面说都很美。很美。
那是一种雕琢。但想象一下那个人来到现在。
不过这也挺浪漫的。我们不妨想想，这就像我们哀叹现代汽车文化时那样，对吧？然后我们会想，哦，当年大家都坐马车的时候是不是更好？
不，并不是。你知道当年纽约用马车做交通工具时是什么味道吗？
是啊，
那就是个露天下水道。马到处拉屎。
是，但你玩过《荒野大镖客》吗？
你知道那些骑马的牛仔有多酷吗？去体验那种怀旧的过去，没有那些乱七八糟的冲动和感觉。
所以基本上，老派的手工编程就像我们美化的牛仔文化，还拍成电影。
这已经在发生了。对手写代码的浪漫化，我也有点这种情怀，因为那是一个非常浪漫的时代。我很庆幸自己经历了20年手写代码还有经济价值的时期。那是
那是一段美好的时光。手写漂亮的代码还有价值。
没错。因为今天手写漂亮代码依然存在，就像昨天一样。有人会特意为Commodore 64、世嘉Mega Drive或其他复古游戏机写新游戏。事实上，
我最近最喜欢的电子游戏之一是……M Retros。你知道Pomaly那边吗？他在重制老游戏机。他重制了Game Boy。
不错。
太棒了。去查查看。真的很酷。但更酷的是，他重制了硬件和原来的厚重感，但用现代屏幕等更新了它。现在他们刚推出了
任天堂64。不可思议。超级酷。对细节、输入延迟和其他东西的极度关注。但还有很酷的一点，我手上有那个wave，就在那里，把鼠标悬停在上面，你就能
看到我在说什么。那就是色彩俄罗斯方块的重制版。我在原版Game Boy上玩了很多俄罗斯方块。可能是我有史以来最喜欢的三大游戏之一。
是的。
他们重写时只改了一处。如果按上键，砖块就会猛砸下来。
嗯嗯。
这一下让游戏速度提升了大约四倍。这游戏太惊艳了，而且它是一款全新的Game Boy游戏。
我记得Game Boy是89年还是88年出的，是台非常老的机器。如今居然还有人写新的老游戏，这太棒了。他们这么做一部分原因是想要俄罗斯方块，但
也有人纯粹是出于对限制的热爱，对那种浪漫情怀的热爱——就像现在还有人骑马，不是为了快速到达某地，而是因为他们喜欢这种交通方式，
一个活生生的生物在你身下驮着你往前走。而且我们也应该说，那种优美的代码是极好的训练数据。所以在某种意义上，我们几十年来构建的美
是的
还在延续。我们孕育了这一刻。
这是何等荣幸。我对此感触很深，因为我写过的几乎所有代码都是公开代码。我职业生涯的绝大部分都献给了开源代码。因此，其中一些代码，一些
优美的代码行，就在训练集里。事实上，我听说人们写Ruby代码时会这么干——他们问智能体："用DHH的风格来写。"
嗯嗯。
而且他们对结果很满意。这多少让我心里一暖，因为我以自己微薄的一小份力量，参与孕育了这一刻。所有贡献过开源代码、或者任何代码的人，只要智能体
在过去——其实是从编程作为一门学科诞生以来的整个时间里——能接触到这些代码，如今都成了这些新智能体霸主的一部分。
所以你就没有一点伤感吗？手工写出漂亮代码这件事，现在越来越没用了。我会难过吗？如果明天我得去找工作，多半没法靠我这身本事，让人付钱给我手工写这些代码。
不会。我干了25年了。我想看点新东西，尤其是如果我们真能永生的话——我倒希望别永生。这个也许以后再说。但那种事，我干够了。
够了，挺好。我不会比不用再拿着锄头下地、不用站流水线更怀念它。
等等，你先别急。你可是世界上最顶尖的程序员之一，能写出手工打磨的漂亮代码，有品位，懂得欣赏美。
没错。
那一切已经被取代了。
我这是谦虚地说。
是啊，那一切已经被取代了。你现在只是在快速进化，能迅速改变想法，这是你特别厉害的一点。但你得把原来那个自己杀掉。
我感激每一个把我带到今天这一步的瞬间，所以我也一直在试着这么做，也许这确实需要练习。我承认，我可能以前不是这样。但斯多葛哲学里的“命运之爱”——热爱你的命运——是一种极其解放的活法。
你可以反驳说，那是因为你有特权。没错。但在我没有这些所谓特权的时候，我也是同样的方向。所以我觉得，有一种活法和与世界互动的方式。
就是接受你能改变的事、接受你改变不了的事，然后爱上这一切。
爱上这个事实吧：今天的技术行业，比去年一下子往前跳了二十年。那我们能聊聊程序员在经历同样转变时普遍的焦虑吗？他们也许上了大学。
主修计算机科学，梦想当程序员、做东西、拿高薪。现在一切都在变，他们深深焦虑：我这辈子该怎么办？你能共情吗？他们到底该怎么办？
他们到底该怎么办？
非常能。正因为我是这种性格，我很清楚这并不平均分布。不是每个人都处在这个位置、都对未来这么乐观。但我想把几件事分开看。
如果你对编程的热爱，只是把正确的逻辑结构拼在一起，做出别人让你做的东西，那这种机械过程正受到威胁，你会很难适应新现实。
但如果你像你刚才说的那样，对做东西本身感到兴奋，那我觉得你根本没有受到威胁。事实上，我甚至觉得有充分理由说，我们需要比现在多得多的创造者。
你看就业数据，其实很模糊，根本看不清会发生什么。有些数据反而显示职位空缺在增加，因为AI让程序的价格大幅下降，人们想要多得多的程序。
这就是经典的杰文斯悖论：当某样东西价格下降，对它的需求反而会增加。ATM也是这个例子。ATM刚出现时，很多银行柜员非常害怕丢工作。
因为突然有台机器能从人们账户里取钱了。但ATM做的是降低了开一家分行的成本，于是银行突然开得起更多分行，结果我们最后拥有的柜员比之前还多。
当然，这些都不是保证。也有真正发生巨变的时刻。直到19世纪末，绝大多数人都在田里干活，然后突然有了机械化收割工具，我们不再需要人拿着锄头、斧头在地里干活了。
那一刻，有机械工具替我们做了。那时候有没有人觉得自己的工作和生计受到威胁？有。
他们为此感到威胁合理吗？合理。英国砸织布机的卢德分子也是一样。我觉得这可能是比农民更好的类比，因为那些人其实是高技能专业人士，做着自己喜欢的工作，条件也相当不错，不是整天在太阳底下当苦力。
但我们如今生活的世界，还会希望衣服是种被严重限制的资源吗？要是这件T恤卖400美元呢？
好吧，那我就有两件了。我的衣柜大概看起来也就两件。但我认为，人类总体的进步依赖生产率的提高。那什么是生产率提高？这非常重要。
因为抽象地讲，我觉得大家都会说：“好啊，生产力，这是好事。”你怎么看？这全是感觉。不，生产力意味着做同样多的事或同样的工作，需要的人更少了。
你想完成的工作量可能会增加，因此你会需要更多人，但也可能不会。有些领域里，公司只需要完成一组固定的任务，突然之间，他们用十分之一的人就能搞定。
对被裁掉的个人来说，这一刻可能是悲剧性的、艰难的。但对整体经济来说，这也是惊人的好事。突然之间，你释放了这些资源，他们现在可以去做更有生产力的事。整个经济就是这样演进和改善的，我们就是这样获得增长的。
增长是好事。我觉得这是另一件需要强力捍卫的事：增长总体来说是好事。我们不想把时钟拨回1920年或1950年。我们应该为发现了新技术、能让我们做多得多的事而兴奋。
虽然有些可能被AI接手的任务是人们原本很乐意做的，只是不再有经济可行性，但很多任务本来只是苦差事。
编程对我来说肯定如此。编程中有一些时刻我觉得太棒了，就是上次我们聊到的那种心流状态，令人狂喜。这种时刻一年里能发生多少次？
如果拿一个普通程序员来说，一年2000小时的工作时间里，这个人有多少时间处于心流状态？
100、200、25。我觉得这些答案对某些人来说都可能是合理的。把这些苦差事交给机器，这就是文明的历史。
是啊，我是说花在调试上的那些时间。编程里有太多太多痛苦的时刻，现在它们大部分都消失了，基本上只剩好玩了。
在很多领域，大部分已经消失了，剩下的可能也很快会消失。所以这也带来了一些浪漫化，因为当下的痛苦是难受的、艰难的、烦人的。但回头看，痛苦就成了成就感、骄傲。
学习、进步，所有这一切，对吧？所以这些都属于人类体验的一部分：我们当下讨厌痛苦，但五分钟过后就珍视它，因为我们不记得艰难，只记得进步。
所以当然，在社会层面、宏观经济层面，增长令人兴奋，但在个人层面，会有很多焦虑，可能有很多痛苦。所以作为建议，如果你现在像年轻的大卫·海涅迈尔·汉森或年轻的开发者、程序员，你会建议他们怎么做？
大卫·海涅迈尔·汉森或年轻的开发者、程序员，你会建议他们怎么做？
别试图预测任何事。你真的会疯掉，因为即使业内最聪明的头脑也无法预测从这里再跳两个模型会是什么样。这绝对是浪费时间。
你会得AI精神病，试图推断两年后会是什么样。专注当下，而现在正是进入计算机领域最不可思议的时代。
如果你投入进去，你能让它们做出最惊人的事。如果你哪怕短暂地强迫自己去了解最前沿在哪里，我敢打赌你不可能不对可能性感到兴奋。至于你推荐公开构建吗？
我觉得公开构建其实是可选的。我觉得这样做挺好，因为这样你就能成为社区的一部分，开源里有一些情谊。不是一些情谊，是大量的情谊。开源是社区和情谊的绝佳来源。
开源是社区和情谊的绝佳来源。它也是遏制那种个人存在主义恐惧的好办法。如果你和其他人在一起，你就能感染上好的思想病毒、令人兴奋的思想病毒。
那些告诉你一切都会好起来、未来一片光明的思想病毒。如果我们一起构建一堆东西，我们就能做到我们谁都没梦想过的事。我刚和瑞安·休斯聊过，他几乎从第一天起就是我在Umachi的主要搭档。
他几乎从第一天起就是我在Umachi的主要搭档。我们昨天还在聊，刚开始这段旅程时，我们的野心非常 modest。我们只是想，能不能让这个DRO别在凌晨三点崩溃。
因为一个我们控制不了的arch包刚被推送出来，那就会很棒了。然后就很好了。现在我们靠在椅背上想，我们怎么接管世界？我们怎么让Omachi上火星？我们怎么做所有我们梦想过的事？
这种野心膨胀，部分是因为有了智能体，事情变好了，但很大程度上也是因为我们身边围绕着对同一段旅程感到兴奋的人。而如果你只是坐在自己孤立的小洞穴里担心未来，是的，你会有点发疯。
坐在自己孤立的小洞穴里担心未来，你会有点发疯。
我觉得如果我们在疫情期间学到了什么，那就是人们独自坐在小洞穴里担心会发生什么，会发疯。那和抑郁没什么区别，无休止地反刍你无法控制的事。
嗯。抱歉我要引用一下Yin和Wong的话，但那只是失败者的话。 你不必做个失败者。你可以选择投入进去并获胜。而获胜的定义非常宽泛：学得更多、创造更多、贡献更多、参与更多。
说到底，你还有得选吗？你根本没得选，兄弟。
未来不管你喜欢不喜欢，它都会来。所以你倒不如选择去兴奋地迎接它。
但我的意思是，我们得强调一个事实：有了AI，做规划几乎是不可能的。我是说，我们大多数人多少都会规划一下人生。年轻的时候，你有希望、有梦想。你上大学是有原因的，背后是有一个规划的。
我同意这一点。我能理解。真的没法好好规划，这事确实挺离谱的，因为你根本不知道——
半年后还有没有Claude Code和Cursor这种东西。也许到时候你就是在跟WhatsApp聊天。也许全是开源代理那种模式。也许全都靠语音了。也许某个模型直接统治世界了。
然后全靠语音。也许操作系统都不存在了。你只是对着一个发光的球体说话就行，因为如果自然语言就足以完成生活中的所有任务——那生活到底是为了什么？
你人生中需要完成的主要任务是什么？如果靠语音就能搞定一切，它帮你写所有程序，所有东西都系统化了，那还需要什么工作？也许更多就是
服务业了。也许根本就不会有程序员、不会有代理工程师了。所以是的，你那个建议很明智——专注当下。但这并不意味着这就只是一趟疯狂的过山车，因为我们不知道
这个十二月、这个一月会变成什么样。
我们不知道。所以，我们应该选择相信一切最终会好起来。这是我应对焦虑最好的建议——在很大程度 上，你可以选择自己往哪边靠。
嗯。
你想不想倾向于那种“末日感”？末日感一定会来。不管你倾向不倾向，你都控制不了。但与此同时，你每天的日程是实实在在的——你学了多少、你做了多少、你
做了多少多元化的事。比如，我最近去了中国农村，而且我是特意去的，因为你在跟中国农村的人聊天，在任何时间过得更慢的地方，那里没人讨论
什么代理工程。我从长城开始的，那东西是永恒的，横跨了几个世纪。你知道，当时有一种错失恐惧的紧张感——也许我错过了什么。
但后来我特意去寻找人类存在的永恒性。真正去感受一个事实：好吧，人类历史上一直感觉一切都在变。但你知道吗，
生活中真正重要的那些普遍真理依然成立。我只是想跟这些保持连接。
你不会错过任何东西。这正是这个转变初期最让我恼火的地方。所有人都那么激动，好像你要是不跟上就完了——“现在是循环了！哦不不，循环过时了，现在是
图了！哦不不，那个也过时了，现在是这个框架那个工具，对吧？”他们不断地在前沿翻来覆去，一方面这确实很让人兴奋。这就是一个新领域打开时会发生的事。就像一个
新的传送门，所有东西都在往外涌。这很激动人心。但这也意味着，如果我过去一年就去背包旅行了，没碰电脑，没见证这个代理时代，我昨天才回来——你猜
怎么着？我两个星期就能赶上。根本没有什么积累，某种意义上是巨大的解脱。如果你错过了过去一年，你两周就能追上最前沿。如果你是个程序员，去喜马拉雅
徒步了一年，回来后，你两周就能赶上。这其实恰恰说明了我们正在经历的进步有多伟大。我们现在同时跑着那么多实验，不断地、
无情地筛选出什么有用、什么没用。你甚至不需要记住或者参与整个历程。你只需要回来直接拿结果就行。但当你背包旅行回来时，关键的一步是——
你愿不愿意变成一个全新的人，因为事情变化太快了。我是说真的，如果你去年十月出发去背包旅行， 然后四五月回来——
那你简直就像在冷冻舱里待了一百年。
就像——“什么叫我们不编程了？”这……这是一个巨大的转变。太令人震惊了。其实，我有些是故意夸张了效果。我也知道，这没关系。
在悲痛中沉浸一会儿。那不符合我的性格，不是我的行事方式。但我承认，那是一种经过时间检验的应对失落感的方式。你曾经熟悉、也许深爱过的世界不再一样了，有失落感是正常的。
也许你曾经深爱过的那个世界已经不再是原来的样子了。
也许我应该大声明确地说，我确实有那种感觉——就像那个印第安人脸上滚落一滴泪，有一种悲伤。这是一场告别。是对编程旧世界的告别。
这对我来说太迷人了。我花了那么多年，但一切都汇聚到了这一刻。对我来说，这正是整段旅程如此有意义的原因。AI不是从天上掉下来的。它不是某种外星科技，轰穿了宇宙，突然出现在我们岸边。
AI从五十年代计算机科学诞生之初就一直存在。当时最聪明的人以为这个问题大概十年就能攻克。结果花了
稍微久一点，但久一点的部分原因是我们通往AI和神经网络的道路上走了些弯路，以为还有其他符号表示方法会胜出，结果并没有。那大概
让我们倒退了大约十五年。另一部分原因是我们得经历游戏革命、3D游戏。如果没有《雷神之锤》，没有《毁灭公爵》，没有《虚幻竞技场》，我们就永远不会得到AI，
因为我们永远不会有GPU，因此永远无法让AI发展到今天这个样子。所以我们直到这一刻所做的一切，都是到达这里的必要条件。
你就是其中一部分。天哪，多大的福分。能有幸贡献你那一小份力量——无论是通过训练还是通过打游戏。真的，你完全可以这样想。所有那些
你花在——对我来说——九十年代只是打游戏的时间，
你都在做贡献。
对。我当时就在为AI革命做贡献，
为人类文明的进步做贡献。没错，当然。文明就是在旧的死亡和新的诞生中前进的，就这样持续下去。但 grieving 的过程仍然是其中的一部分。我觉得
给自己一点时间。没关系的。而且，你甚至不必接受一切都死了。如果你仍然非常执着于手工凿刻——如果你一年前问我，我会预测我会
更加执着。我竟然
我有点惊讶
自己没有那么执着。但我没那么执着的原因，我想是我找到了更有趣的东西。如果不是这样，如果AI只是取代了我爱的东西，给了我一个我讨厌的东西，我大概会
好受一点。
我的意思是，这真的感觉——看起来又好笑又精彩，还鼓舞人心。就像毕加索突然获得了图像生成的能力，超级兴奋，几个月内就转向了。那
真的就是发生的事。就像一个欣赏优美代码的艺术家，突然你就在谈论乐趣了。
我觉得毕加索其实是个很好的类比，因为如果你看他早期学艺时的作品，那是写实绘画，对吧？他在训练自己成为以我们当时所知的最佳方式描绘现实的大师。
然后出现了所有这些其他的表达形式。立体主义来了，还有各种抽象表现主义。他并没有哀叹自己不再画文艺复兴式的画了，不再只画一个完美的
苹果的完美再现。他把苹果重新想象成一个该死的方块。他为此兴奋。我感觉就是这种转变——我们从一种表达模式，突然打开了大门，
就像色谱一下子宽了那么多。我看到更多了。也许这和我成为程序员的方式有关。我成为程序员不是因为深爱 if 语句。我成为程序员是因为我想要程序。
我想要不存在的东西存在。起初我得学会编程才能实现。然后我碰巧爱上了编程这门手艺。然后我花了二十年真正深入其中。但现在我回来了。我回到了
有个想法，就迫不及待想看到它成真。而AI几乎把这个过程压缩到了零。所以，这是一种加速的再发现。当然，我明白这对每个人来说不都是这样。有很多
程序员从一开始就热爱编程，被逻辑结构之类的东西吸引。我是说，我自己也这样做了二十年，我懂的。但我也觉得，如果你愿意接纳它，你能
发现自己新的一面。我又回到这个几乎算是遗憾最小化框架的思路，借用贝索斯的话。两年后你回头看自己，会想：“唉，我
当时把时间都花在抱怨现状、抱怨我的行业变了。”还是两年后回头看这一刻，会为自己主动拥抱变化而骄傲，也许中间还有过一段哀伤？这些
情绪都是正常的，然后说：我要学会这个世界现在怎么运转，我不只是要尽量利用它，我要创造更多。确实是这样。很多程序员，我很多朋友，当然还有你
都在享受乐趣。过去三个月我玩电脑玩得比以前任何时候都开心。
先快速上个厕所，然后我得问问你，现在你实际上是怎么跟这些系统交互的。
好。
我得问问你，你的配置——编程配置——怎么变了？键盘、语音、用什么IDE？现在想起来都觉得疯狂，但没错，我用TextMate用了快二十年。
我从2005年左右开始用TextMate。我帮忙推出了第一个版本，然后就一直没兴趣换。我根本没在找替代品。直到换到Linux，我才被迫离开了
我的舒适区。现在随着转向——我们管它叫什么？代理工程？我讨厌这个词。我们得想个听起来跟“编程”一样朴素的词，但又能体现它是跟代理一起做的。但
我还是觉得就该叫编程。
行，那就叫编程吧。
对，
跟代理一起编程确实需要不同的工具。真的。最大的变化是，你从脑子里单线程编程变成了并行处理。以前我写代码，在TextMate甚至Neovim里手工雕琢——那也没多久以前——我一次只专注一个问题，有条不紊地推进，那其实就是进入心流的入口。心流的入口就是深度沉浸
在TextMate或
于单个问题，从头看到尾。
嗯。
跟代理一起就不是这样了。部分原因是代理既太快又太慢。你让它做件事，它不会立刻给你回复。这跟敲键盘不一样。所以你得让代理
先跑一会儿
。然后你意识到，如果我干坐着等它们，首先，那感觉不高效。就算一个代理本身可能非常高效，你也不觉得高效。是不是
感觉不太好？其实会让你觉得自己有点没用。嗯。
也许我经历过一个阶段，最早的代理时刻到来时，我基本一次只跑一个代理，那时我觉得“这玩意儿我说不好”，但很多难题你确实可以通过砸更多资源来解决。这
就是AI本身的规模定律，对吧？如果你把这些并行起来，不是跑一个代理，而是同时跑好几个，你就能感觉自己处于心流状态，因为你一直在做编程工作——你的
一直在做决策，帮某个代理解卡，因为它问你该往哪个方向走，或者你准备好接新任务了。要做到这一点，你需要不同的配置。我一开始是在
终端标签页和分屏。基本上，可以把终端想象成标签页——你打开一堆标签页。我觉得大多数人都清楚那是怎么运作的，没人只用一个标签页工作。
所以，你还是坚守终端命令行界面。
当然。所以你不用 Cloud Code 应用或者 Codeex 应用，对吧？
我特别喜欢这场智能体革命是从终端发起的，因为我本来就是终端用户界面和终端的超级粉丝，那种感觉就像——[吸气]——一个非常舒服的地方。它是
一个很美的地方。现代终端就是个好看的工作场所。所以我喜欢这一点。而且当你不止在自己的机器上跑多个智能体，而是开始跑多台机器的时候，
光靠终端标签页已经不够追踪了。所以最近我换到了一个叫 Herder 的东西。Herder 本质上就是终端标签页加上智能体通知。所以
每当你的智能体完成任务或者需要你做什么，它就叮一下，响个小铃，告诉你它准备好等人类了——它是主人还是仆人，我也说不准——总之它准备好要做决定了。而且它还会追踪这些——是
不是在工作模式。所以我有一套 Herder 配置，实际上我在每台机器上都跑着不同的 Herder。大概一个月前，我经历了一段疯狂时期，意识到在单台机器上做这活儿不够快。就像我
发现了多核编程，可只有两个核。我就想，要是有16个核呢？32个核呢？64个核呢？于是，我立刻出去买了这些超棒的 KVM，叫 GLI.NET Comets。
嗯嗯。
它们就是个小盒子。你插上 HDMI，插上 USB，连到电脑上。它就像个 KVM。KVM 是一种远程控制电脑的方式。但特别之处在于它用起来太简单了。
你把这东西接上，打开一个网页，登录一次，设一个密码，然后它就能接入你的 Tailscale 网络。
嗯。过去一年对我的另一场革命，就是发现了这些 WireGuard 网络。Tailscale 本质上就是把你所有电脑变成一个局域网，不管你在哪儿。
比如现在，我用手机就能直接访问我在马里布办公室的所有电脑。我也能访问我在哥本哈根办公室的所有电脑。
我可以像坐在它们旁边一样操作，不用在防火墙上打洞，也不用设置复杂的 VPN。这带来的效果就是，把新算力上线的摩擦降到了极低。
所以，我一发现这个，就翻了我的储物柜，发现之前实验留下一堆迷你主机。我就想，干脆把它们全连上？
哦，哇。
我就把储物柜里的四台电脑连上了。它们都配了小 Comet，突然之间我就能同时在更多电脑上跑智能体，还能用 Herder 全部控制起来。后来确实到了
我把自己处理能力榨干的程度，我想大概是四到五台机器在跑，
不知道，每台三个智能体吧，我大概能跑16个线程，这就是我的上限。当然，智能体跑得越快，能跑的线程就越少，但按目前速度，我能全速跑大约16个线程。
这也是为什么我从对智能体时代感到兴奋，变成有点神志不清。因为就像你说的，其中有些东西有点冲击性——我们的电脑带宽还处在拨号上网的水平。
我是说，这其实挺搞笑的。你想，一年前我坐在这儿，对吧？我在凿代码，一行行写。花一个小时，我能写出一个漂亮的控制器或者一个
漂亮的模型，就一个文件，我真是精雕细琢。所以可能最后剩60行。也许我当时的带宽大概是每小时30行。我觉得那都算高了，可能每小时20行。现在呢，
我跑着16个线程，有时候每小时产出几百行代码，甚至每小时几百行。现在，让我在这儿暂停一下。我讨厌那个指标，对吧？用代码行数来衡量这些东西本来就很蠢。
一般来说，用代码行数衡量这些东西就是蠢。我觉得编程社区里有些人嘲笑那种AI狂热是对的——当大家都在说自己写了多少行代码，你问他们到底建了什么，
然后吧，就是没有好的答案出来，对吧？
这只是一个好用的简写。
确实是个好用的简写。它是一种表示或概括，表示现在输出了多少内容，至于这个输出是好是坏，
并不是对它的一种公投评判。但我过去产出、现在产出都比以前多得多，对吧？因此我能同时推进所有这些线程。这就是整体设置。它仍然是 Neovim，但到了这个阶段，我写代码已经不多了，所以我是用
Neovim 当项目浏览器用，然后用它来启动 LazyGit，看已有的变更日志。就连这个，我也得说，如果 GitHub 展示你的 pull request 能再快一点，网页端其实可能是更好的
选择。我不知道。还有个我最近在玩的工具叫 Hunk，它能以非常好用的方式生成 diff。所以你也可以看看那个。但我发现，我看 Hunk 的时候，只能
看到变更集。而当我审查来自 agent 的输出时，我经常想看到周围的上下文。哦，对。所以改了这个文件，但实际上另一个没被碰过的文件里有什么内容，也许本来
应该被改的。所以这就是为什么我仍然喜欢用 Neovim 来做这件事。嗯，不过顺带一提，这一切当然都发生在 Amachi 上。所以都发生在 Linux 上。这也是 agent 带来的另一个重大突破。Agent 喜欢
Unix 哲学。它喜欢那些可以通过命令行调用的独立工具。而地球上主流操作系统中——我这里数三个：Mac、Windows、Linux——没有哪个能像 Linux 那样
完美配合这种机制。在 Linux 里，一切要么是配置文件，要么是 CLI 工具。而就在五分钟前，这还曾是它的主要缺点。这就是人们不喜欢 Linux 的原因。就像，全都是配置文件和命令行工具。
多么大的讽刺啊。宇宙跟我们开了个玩笑，五分钟前 Linux 的缺点，现在反而成了它的主要卖点。
这是我觉得自己被困住的一件事。四个月前，我有个周末带着 Mac 出门。我以为我要去的地方有台 Linux 机器，所以没带自己的笔记本。到了才发现，我只有一台 Mac Mini。所以，我只好在糟糕处境里尽量做好，按我一直在琢磨的 Linux 方式
配置我的 Mac。其实现在你能做很多了。Homebrew 已经变得相当不错。Homebrew 是 Mac 缺失的包管理器，在让 Mac 在易用性方面
向前发展这件事上，没人比它贡献更大。但仍然，像 Raycast 这么简单的东西。我不知道你用过没有。就是那个
它没有你可以直接访问的配置文件。你得进图形界面，导出文件，然后拿着那个文件，我不知道，塞进你该死的背包里放 U 盘上，
然后才能在别的地方导入。你没法自动化整台机器的设置。你根本没法自动化 Mac 默认键位的配置。嗯。
那就得是个手动过程，你得像个原始人一样用鼠标点来点去，才能设置好你的机器。
我是说，有变通办法。
但都不好。我看过，我努力试过。
所以，这就是我的历程。显然我是 Linux 用户，但因为 Adobe Premiere、Adobe 那些产品，我也是 Windows 用户。所以很多时候我会用 WSL，也就是 Windows 的 Linux 子系统。所以是 Windows 里面的 Linux，这在
agent 时代，不是一种好用的 Linux，因为它只是
它是个沙盒。
它是个沙盒，而你希望 Linux 被放出来，能无所不能。
没错。
所以我现在开始关注 Raycast 这类东西。你知道，我是键盘党。配置文件在哪里？我能不能，嗯，基本上让 agent 把所有东西都替我设置好，并把配置保存下来，这样我
可以在各个系统间复制，一切都自动化了。所以我不得不问很多这样的问题，而其中很多都缺失了。
他们给不出好的答案。
但很多时候你其实可以自己动手做这个应用。
但有一些变通办法。
那些都是变通办法。
是有变通办法。你不必这样过日子，Lex。有更好的办法。其实，这是个绝佳时机。
除非你有个视频剪辑师。
所以，这是个好时机。
对。
嗯，我听说今天是你的生日。
所以，呃，我带了个小礼物。
不会吧。
不管你喜欢不喜欢，我们都要让你用上Aentic操作系统。
太棒了。
然后我，呃，我问了我在戴尔的朋友，呃，看他们有没有一台机器，嗯，我可以，呃，我可以送给你当生日礼物。所以，这是我用的机器，跟我是同款，但现在归你了。这是一台戴尔XPS14。
已经装好了Omachi 4，随时可以为你配置。
而且，嗯。
一旦你意识到你所有的……顺便说一句，我们几乎可以掐个表计时。你就能跑起来了。
你大概要在1分钟内回答5个问题。要是你想，你完全可以现场就做。呃，Omachi，DHH做的漂亮的现代风的Linux。对，咱们来做吧。
对，你边弄边听我说。所以。
酷。
正是你意识到的那样，Mac上那种痛苦，我体验了大概一个周末，我拼命试，找到了一些还算不错的变通办法。主要的那个就是Homebrew现在有图形界面应用的标签页了，因为这真是好笑。
回想不久以前，人们会去像“我要Zoom”这样的网站。他们会输入Zoom.com，找到下载链接，下载一个DMG文件，双击它，看到一个奇怪的手动操作提示，让他们把一个图标从一个地方拖到屏幕上的另一个地方。
从屏幕的一个地方拖到另一个地方。你就是这样安装应用的。你就这样一遍又一遍地做，直到你把想要的应用都装齐。如果你在配置一台新机器，而你有大概12个应用，
你得跑去十二个不同的网站下载，简直跟原始人一样。Homebrew 解决了很多，但没全解决，在这一点上更是完全没解决——
抱歉打断一下，你看这速度。
哦，大概四十秒就搞定了。
然后你就进入——
Super 就是你键盘上的 Windows 键或 Command 键。那到底哪个是 super 键？
对，那就是 Windows 键。哦不对不对，你这台是特别版。
全世界大概只有六台这样的电脑。
哦，这儿有个 super 键。
上面写着 super。再看键盘另一头那个 Copilot 键的位置。
那是 Machi 的 logo。
不错，好，酷。
这是 Spencer Bull 在 Bell 做的，我跟他合作了很多这方面的事。他们太厉害了。他们一度放弃了 XPS 这个品牌。
对，去年他们就这么干了。
我当时就想，这也太蠢了。XPS 多牛啊。
砍掉 XPS 品牌还不只是蠢。他们还把 Esc 键干掉了，顶部换成了电容触摸按钮。苹果三年前就意识到那是个糟糕的错误，大家都恨透了——
那种设计。但现在他们有个超棒的团队，而这其实是我第一台自己用的戴尔笔记本。嗯。
因为我服务器一直在用戴尔。我们脱离云端靠的就是戴尔。从 2000 年代中期起我们就跑戴尔了，好像是吧。但我从没用过他们的笔记本，因为跟 MacBook 比，对我来说根本不够用。
不够用。2016 年那批 XPS，或者说搭载英特尔 Panther Lake 芯片的这批，是我第一台个人真正会用的戴尔。有意思的是，当初我对苹果生气时，我想，你知道吗？我干脆买台戴尔，反正我们已经在用了。结果我买了台戴尔，
然后我想，天哪，这不行。不够好。可谁知道，今年他们把所有问题都解决了。电池续航解决了，
性能解决了。兼容性解决了。重量解决了。屏幕也解决了。那是串联 OLED 屏。
太牛了。这意味着它的技术甚至比该死的 MacBook 还好。比 MacBook 还轻，芯片终于有竞争力了，因为英特尔花了整整五年开发 18A 制程。
花了很久，但现在它来了，简直不可思议。我们终于有了能跟苹果 M 芯片抗衡的对手——
续航一样长，性能也能打。而且这机器有个漂亮的默认主题。还有，那个叫什么？Super 加空格打开——
其实你直接按那个 Amachi 键就行。它打开菜单。这样你就能控制一切了。
跟超级空间一个道理。
所以对我来说这是个巨大的变化——我们终于有了不用找借口的 Linux 机器。
因为（清嗓）我不介意找借口，因为借口其实只是权衡的另一种说法。我很喜欢 Framework 13，上次好像聊过。我现在依然喜欢它，他们还在做不错的电脑，但是
我觉得对很多人来说，他们不想要那种将就的体验。他们想要开箱就觉得质感、做工各方面都跟 Mac 平起平坐的东西，现在这东西终于有了。所以，生日快乐。
太谢谢了。还收到一台 DHH 送的 Machi Dell 笔记本，这是最好的生日礼物。太棒了。对了，看看这个屏保。是的，挺惊艳的。我正看着它
在那块 tandem OLED 屏幕上。简直不可思议地帅。
瞧瞧这个。
整体有种复古的感觉。就像在 90 年代跑一个公告板系统，而我 14 岁那年干的就是这个。所以对我来说完全是种怀旧，一种很棒的美学——把现代
兴起的 Unix 文化跟这种复古的
90 年代味道结合起来。是的，就像给一个智能体优先的操作系统配了张复古脸。太疯狂了。
这又刚好配上了——这也是为什么我那么兴奋：所有这些智能体框架是以 TUI、CLI 的形式出现的，是以
终端的形式出现的，因为突然之间，新一代的程序员和普通用户都发现了终端的魅力。终端其实是我们能拥有的最厉害、最高效的用户界面之一。后来我们
又做了更容易上手的界面。鼠标是个了不起的发明，让不太懂电脑的人也能点来点去、摸索出东西。但终端是给那些想要
了解自己系统、想学键盘命令的人用的。
所以，你觉得嗯……你觉得 TUI 会一直存在吗？
百分之百。不过，它不会是唯一的东西。当然不是，因为这些实验室现在都是万亿美元估值了。他们得触达几十亿人，而我不觉得我们会教几十亿人
去搞懂 TUI 的那些门道。所以我们会用别的工具，而且已经有别的工具了。顺便说一句，这也正是 Linux 的一个可爱之处——那个 ChatGPT Codex 工具。
对，我看到了
那个消息发布后不到两小时。我就把它打包好、准备好了。现在如果你去……你其实可以按那个 Omachi 键
嗯。然后直接输入 ChatGPT。它应该会弹出来，比如显示安装。然后按回车就行。
输入 Lex 的密码。
对。你输什么都行。然后它就会装上。装完就弹出来，你就有 ChatGPT 了。
不错。
很多应用就是这么装的。所有智能体框架都是这么内置的。嗯，比如我提过的 Tailscale，你想连上就是这个方式。Dropbox 也是。这些东西之所以都在里面，就是因为我用它们。
因为我这套系统是为我自己造的。我首先想的是，怎么给我自己造一台梦想中的电脑？如果我造出了我的梦想电脑，我就确信肯定还有别人跟我的梦想一样。
你对把安装时间压到一分钟以内这件事特别执着。网上好多人问你为什么，为什么你就非得让安装时间少于60秒？先说个事，我想引用Mitchell
Himoto的一句话。他做了Ghosty Terminal，很棒，Nachi上也能用，他还是HashiCorp的创始人。他前不久在X上发了个帖子，里面有句特别狠的话：追求卓越，无需解释。
想把东西做到尽可能好、尽可能快、尽可能美，这本身就无需理由。
嗯。
我们就该追求那些漂亮、快速、用起来轻巧的系统。说到安装时间，有意思的是，一开始其实不是冲着一分钟去的。我起步的时候挺保守的。我想的是，如果能把整个系统
15分钟装好，那比起以前已经是巨大的进步了，我就心满意足了。这事的起因是，测试基准早就跑偏得没边了。你说过
Commodore 64是你的第一台电脑，对吧？
你拆开那台Commodore 64，按下开机键，我记得不到一秒，Basic解释器就准备好接收命令了。几乎是瞬间的事，基本没有开机
时间。你知道我为了在Linux上跑一个我至今还没搞定的应用——Adobe Lightroom——买的那台新Mac，装好用了多久吗？
嗯。
全新电脑，刚拆封。我开始设置。有软件更新。我还没准备好装Adobe Lightroom呢，得先把它更新到最新，这一路花了我42分钟。太丑了，太荒唐了。这是对所有喜欢
电脑的人的侮辱。你买了台新电脑，还没用呢，得先花42分钟给那些出厂就装好的东西做更新。简直离谱。更疯的是
这还不是最糟的。我还买了台PC，因为那些Linux机器都是PC形态的嘛，出厂都预装Windows。
所以我也买了一台。就三周前的事。全新机器，Intel Panther Lake，全套配置。从拆封到能用，1小时35分钟。你觉得我等了多久才进Numachi？
肯定不到一分钟。
一分钟。
对。
我们明明能造出这样的电脑。技术是有的。1981年Commodore 64出来的时候就有了。现在我们的电脑快了一万亿倍，结果你还得花42分钟、一个半小时去设置才能用，这让我太火大了，火大到变成了执念。有意思的是，刚才休息的时候我跟Ryan Hughes聊，就是我在这儿
的共谋者。我们现在觉得找到了一条路子，能给特定电脑做预制的turbo镜像，因为它依赖对硬件的了解，比如Dell XPS。我们要做一个Dell
XPS的turbo镜像，大约12秒就能装完。
完整的Linux系统
大约12秒装好。
太不可思议了。正是这种执念，让我从用电脑这件事里得到巨大的满足——我们不接受现状。也正因如此，我现在所栖身的这个被智能体加速的现实，才这么让人振奋。因为我可以看着这些
限制条件说，你知道吗……
我本可以在5分钟的时候就停下来。那已经够快了。X上就有人争论，对吧？你干嘛还要继续？5分钟够快了。好吧，对你来说也许够了，但对我来说12秒有趣多了。
而且我总是想，试着从第一性原理出发思考。好了，在那台机器上再按一下那个omachi键，然后选速度。你会看到一个列表弹出来，其中一个就是磁盘速度，
速度测试、网络速度、磁盘速度，
磁盘速度。选那个然后运行。这就是在测内置NVME硬盘的性能。你测出来多少？
每秒7GB。
每秒7GB。这就是那块硬盘的速度。那为什么我们不能在1秒内装好一个Linux发行版？Omachi发行版是5.8GB。
嗯。
如果我们能跑到7G的速度。当然，实际上做不到，因为USB盘比这慢多了，但你应该能够把底层物理和协议的性能压榨到极致。那就是你的
目标。我们得一路回到那个层面。对，我很喜欢你做Linux发行版，因为你可以做任何东西，但你选择做一个Linux发行版，意味着你在重新思考计算机
是什么，因为操作系统是基础，是你和计算机交互的根基
而它已经陈旧太久了。
对。
我们今天用的Mac OS和10年前的Mac OS几乎没什么区别。事实上在很多方面还更糟，因为苹果不断加强对用户的控制。他们不想让用户安装他们没点头同意的软件。
他们不想让用户重新配置快捷键，除非手动去做。他们不想改掉切换工作区那500毫秒的动画。这是一台令人恼火的封闭计算机。平心而论，
苹果的封闭电脑做得还不错，但我不想要封闭的电脑。我想拥有我的电脑。更好的是，我想改造我的电脑。而这就是智能体时代需要新操作系统的原因。
当你能凭感觉就写出任何想到的应用时，你也应该能凭感觉写出你的操作系统。你应该能改任何东西：外观、运作方式、有哪些面板、哪些没有。而这就
需要Linux。就这么简单。另外两个操作系统都做不到这一点。
但你能谈谈吗，我记得有人问过你，你算老几，凭什么觉得你能比Ubuntu做得更好？或者说Ubuntu已经挺好的了，你为什么还要做？你的回答是，我觉得我能做得更好。那你能
谈谈吗，这是在X上的。你能谈谈这种疯狂劲是从哪来的，让你觉得你一个人，或者和Ryan一起，就能做出比Ubuntu或Arch之类更好的东西？
这么说吧，我刚开始Linux之旅时并没有那么宏大。其实我就是从Ubuntu开始的，然后在上面搭建。这个系统已经做了很多我想做的事，
至少它是Linux。那我能不能在它上面搭建，让它更现代、更好看、装上我想用的程序？我大概做出了那么个版本。然后我发现，
还能再深入七层。你越接近底层，越接近内核，越接近各个软件包，你发现的自由就越多。所以当我发现越来越多的自由，我就变得
越来越有野心。然后我意识到，毫不意外，我对计算机应该怎么运作、该长什么样、该装什么程序、是该花42分钟还是45秒安装，都有强烈的看法。顺便说一句，
45秒是目前的世界纪录。所以，如果谁在这之后装了M Quattro还能打破45秒，截个图发给我，你就是新的世界纪录保持者。
你是什么时候突破60秒大关的？说起来挺有意思，因为就像那个，以前有个人类极限，是什么来着？1952年的4分钟一英里还是什么的。
人们曾以为人类根本不可能打破。然后有一个人打破了，紧接着几个月内又有三个人做到了，对吧？
所以我们有了这个目标。一开始是两分钟。
然后我们打破了两分钟，我就想，既然能破两分钟，为什么不能破一分钟？我记得当时觉得那简直疯了。你不可能在一分钟内装好一个现代操作系统，别的系统都要42分钟，对吧？
苹果那么多聪明人，装个系统也要42分钟。那这应该就是标杆了吧。不，不，这不是标杆，因为根本没有速度上限。那些你以为理所当然的事情，
在几乎所有情况下都不是现实的固定支柱。除非你达到那块硬盘每秒7GB的传输极限，否则你还没到顶。所以你就该继续往前推。当然，这就变成了一场
游戏，本身就是一种满足。每能省下一秒钟都让我兴奋。当我们突破一分钟大关时——我想那大概是三周前，甚至可能是两周前的事——我简直疯了。
然后我搞了一群智能体去跑各种自动研究循环，尝试各种不同的理论，比如，改这个会怎样，改那个会怎样，把这个砍掉会怎样？如果
并行处理呢？如果在你输入用户名的时候，我们就开始把软件包预加载进内存系统，能不能更快启动？这就变成了一个有趣的游戏。我觉得你就该这样看待
产品开发。它应该是有趣的，应该是不拘一格的。应该去超额完成目标，让它远远好过所谓的“刚需”。
尤其是现在，因为你可以行动得这么快。因为有智能体，你可以尝试很多不同的方法。
是的，这只会让它更令人满足。但我觉得这一点一直成立。你看看史上最伟大的奔驰，我记得叫W126，我看过一部很棒的纪录片。主导这个项目的人，
在奔驰安全部门干了很多年，突然被调去负责整个S级项目，他就把所有东西都堆了上去。自动收紧安全带、大灯清洗器等等，
全都有。这辆车对市场来说过度设计了，简直难以置信。但你看它就会说：“我也想要那个。”
就像你看一块机械表，心想它能下潜100米，或者劳力士有一款能下潜4000米，去深海，深潜者海洋什么的。
全世界除了三个人，根本没人会买那块表去真的测试它。但你难道不想成为那种人吗——去赞助那些想推动人类向前一大步的人？我想要
最快的车去打破速度极限。我想要能下潜马里亚纳海沟的潜水表。我想要能在一分钟以内装好的操作系统。所以从个人层面，我敬佩那些人。我觉得每个人都应该追求
这个。但我们也该提一下它的后果，比如对卓越的追求，即便指标看起来没什么意义，它可能带来的意外结果是其他种类的卓越、发现、创新等等，
那些和速度毫无关系的东西。
百分之百。
是发现。你追逐的那个指标能成为催化剂、成为驱动创新的引擎，这很好，因为你总会有所发现。这跟你去月球、去火星是同一个道理。为什么？谁在乎？
其实真正重要的是，你会对化学推进了解很多。你会了解人类如何在太空长期生存。也许你会发现全新的在太空做太阳能的方式，或者太空数据中心之类的。
各种各样的可能，也许你还会遇到外星人，谁知道呢。但设定一个目标并去追逐它，尤其是当它是数字化的目标时，真的很棒。
而设定一个宏大的目标就更好了。当你拒绝只做实际可行的事，而是追求略微超出可能性的东西时，奇迹就会发生。我们应该全力以赴。这也是其中一个
原因。事实上，在某种程度上，这个具体目标就是受到别人做法的启发。我是说，马斯克是这场对话中独一无二的人物。他的目标如此超前，乍一看似乎荒谬至极。
我肯定在很多次看的时候都觉得它们荒谬。然后你意识到，它们有时候真的会实现。也许不总是按计划。那又怎样？那又怎样？我们没按计划实现自动驾驶，那又怎样？我给过马斯克很多
那在17年就有人想到了，但现在它成真了。除了那个在17年就相信这事可能的人，还有谁能把我们带到这里？他对现实如此不耐烦，那股纯粹的力量就是要推动现实，去到他想要的地方。
我觉得这特别鼓舞人心，我们需要这种标杆被挪动。我们需要有人跑进四分钟一英里，这样我们其他人才能明白：好吧，我想我也能跑得更快。这就是我努力追求的东西，我真的在拼命追求，
用Mach（可能指某个项目/工具）去追求，因为那样活着更有意思，有更高的抱负和野心。我得说，其实我在这点上改了点想法。我花了挺多时间讲另一本书，说有很多人其实并不
真的需要那些野心。这也是真的。我们不想要80亿个马斯克到处跑。我觉得世界会疯掉。但我逐渐意识到，对创业者来说，有合适的、够分量的目标是健康的。那种只是
开个意大利餐厅的想法，不能只是那样。也许我就开这一家意大利餐厅，但我要做出最棒的披萨。我要做出最美味的帕尔马干酪。我们必须追求卓越，才能攒够动力继续走下去，
对。要敢于想大一点，比如你可以构建一个Linux
是的。
发行版。有没有一些你记得的、让我们变得这么快的东西？你提到了一些方面，是那些代理在发现的。